what's going on guys the mutants are
returning school is back in session what
school professor X's school for gifted
youngsters x-men apocalypse hitting
theaters I'm pretty excited but I have
been asking myself a question maybe some
of you have been asking what's the deal
with apocalypse so today we are going to
please explain apocalypse and we got a
couple of really cool dudes who know
they're here to talk with us today first
he is one of the co-hosts of Marvel
movie news he is an actor writer bon
vivant quois and row and he's a writer
for geek & sundry and he's a comedian
sacks carthon let's begin at the
beginning to me about the origin of this
character apocalypse origin was like a
bad improv sketch people keep adding on
to it as it goes on so he started and
the care yes he's yeah yeah so he starts
out he's a mutant in Egypt okay and he's
born with gray skin and blue lips and
eventually he fights Rama Todd he beats
Rama Todd who goes back into
time-traveling and leaves him alone he
becomes pharaoh or it becomes the leader
of the clan Aqaba and then and also
steals Rama Tut's like assistant
Ozymandias who's like a Android made of
sand he's now got mutant powers and
time-traveling powers and a sand assist
that he finds a celestial ship
Celestials are like the big godlike
creatures of the Marvel Universe and he
spends years researching it and he gains
all the celestial powers because he also
gets infected with not one but two
techno-organic viruses and he gains the
power to control the ship and that's the
character that is introduced to fight
the x-men like you know 5,000 years
later so you guys just laid out a
complex and layered origin if they put
that origin in the movie yeah we're
looking at a 7-hour oh please it's the
Godfather Jessen apocalypse right yeah
way to make that and it's all entirely
unnecessary to because basically all you
need to know is that he has like access
to all these crazy powers and his powers
list it like is is incredible
telekinesis telepathy my favorite is
techno path II where you can effectively
control technology through telepathy oh
that's um Stephen King maximum always
yes time cook always all of Stephen
King's books is the problem he has all
these abilities and any has molecular
control or like
atomic control which effectively is
writers not knowing what control he has
and called it molecular you just do what
everyone
I think Fox will use the gross the
stretching the telepathy in the
telekinesis I imagine because anything
beyond that I mean that's already plenty
talk to me about the four horsemen and
their evolution in the comics
well basically every time he comes back
from his stasis he has these new four
horsemen he picks them he selects them
and they become his clan like his his
basically his tribe that he sends out
first to uncover which mutants are
worthy he believes in survival of the
fist and these people are kind of like
the people that he sends out to find out
who are the fists if we assure them he
has like the four horsemen that are so
named he has like death pestilence war
and they're all new characters initially
way later he he shows up again and now
he's got angel the war in Washington
character who everyone thought was dead
he's back as his Angel of Death
Archangel and that got them all started
on like every time he shows up now he'd
have like like four mutants you knew
we've had Wolverine we've had gambit
we've had the more like 90s iconic and
archangels really important because
that's kind of like when you think
apocalypse using Archangel in the comics
now let me ask you this who are some of
apocalypses traditional foes I know all
the x-men but who are some of the ones
that pop up in the most prominent
storyline he's trying to like evolve
humanity and he's like sort of survival
the fittest thing he's trying to steal
powers from the x-men or steal powers
from particular individuals the x-men
protect at some point he tried to he
inhabited Scott Summers Cyclops his body
cable and him fought back and forth
through time and strife was a clone of
cable that attempted to kill in multiple
times and then strife became a major
character in the 90s and then mr.
sinister fought him and Ozymandias was
an enemy at a few points so basically
everyone that all the night every rocket
burns can you tell us with your
familiarity of the comics what are they
using from the comics as far as um story
arcs for this movie well I don't think
they'll go with the main one I don't
think the Age of Apocalypse because
that's the most to me characters they
can't use it involves like Wolverine
losing his hand there's too much story
they're basically restarting x-factor
having the original team and I think
they're gonna use his origin story but
only like yes at the origin he's
probably been asleep and he wakes up and
decides to like now it's time to take
over the world again he recruits the
four horsemen who we'll see including
angel will probably see be recruited and
then the x-men try to oppose him but
they've got nothing now what are his
weakness how do they defeat this is it
okay he he needs to go into some kind of
stasis and recharge his powers but what
how is this guy vulnerable yeah that's
the problem the artery's one big thing
like yeah they're just gonna fight him
till he's sleepy it's probably I'll
probably overextend that's usually the
way they do it in comics is he'll I do
think you're gonna feel watching the
movie like and all the characters will
feel like he's unstoppable
yeah um and then they'll just fight him
and fight him fight him and he'll like
you know like I'll just keep drawing
power into this fight until then she's
like Oh too much or they'll use the
horsemen against him and because they're
drawing from his power they can hurt her
okay all right whatever all right you're
saying there's some possibilities there
if our viewers who aren't as familiar
with the comics want to explore
apocalypse in the comics what would you
suggest
I'd suggest the Age of Apocalypse
miniseries it was such a big miniseries
that it turned into regular continuity
they were gonna have to be a one-off
yeah it turned into the regular
continuity in that world and other
comics imitated it it changed comics in
the night there is a there is an
apocalypse origin
like many series called I think birth of
apocalypse
they've been really easy for you
everything that apocalypse has ever been
in has the word apocalypse in the titles
by and large okay there is your so so if
you go by a trade paperback that has
apocalypse in it that will be one of his
stories all right um sometimes I like to
ask dumb questions I know these things
do not relate in the current cinematic
universes but how do apocalypse his
powers compared to Thanos I'd say on par
he's someone that could compete with
Thanos as far as pure strength and the
confusion of powers oh and also because
Thanos and apocalypse require some sort
of MacGuffin to defeat like they they
they show up unstoppable yeah and then
they're like but I hope nobody finds the
crystal of defeating me and then
somebody does and that's the end of my
who'd win a fight then let's
carpocalypse well I mean Marvel's
already won the fight so oh yeah there
you go
what's something you hope to see in the
movie ooh I hope to see a character that
is more fleshed out than the comics ever
could be because it has one set of
writers so I want to see an apocalypse
that makes sense you know in a post
Captain America Civil War world I'd like
to see them do enough service for each
of the characters that it seems like
they all have a reason to be there
what
is not very easy to do but now that
we've seen it so recently I don't want a
movie in which storm doesn't have a
reason to exist like I want I want I
want I want a moment for all the
characters they have and they've got so
many now I feel like I'm swimming with
information now but you guys really drop
some knowledge are you looking forward
to the movie what are you excited about
what are you a little bit nervous about
what character you most excited to see
let us know in the comments section
below we want to know I want to thank my
guest you guys you really brought it you
brought knowledge quois Andrew sacks car
thanks for being here thank you for
watching I'm how Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye